good morning how's everyone doing this
morning
i'm so happy to be here is my honor to
give you a keynote on a very very
abridged history of application security
the whole point i'm trying to make here
is not to discuss the problems of
application security but to show you
things are getting better we're making
progress this is an incredibly important
topic for all of humanity i know a lot
of us who are in the field working on
this problem it is stressful it is
difficult it is like a salmon
swimming uphill most of the time but
when you're inside of the problem facing
it it's gonna seem like we're not making
much progress but the point of this
keynote is we're going to zoom out we're
going to take a look at application
security from the last 50 years and from
that perspective i think we're going to
see that things are getting a lot better
it's all about perspective the reason i
like doing keynotes is for one reason
only so i can get keynote selfies with
all of you let's do this you can't just
sit there i need like a little i need a
little something so ready ready come on
give me something
yeah
one more one more
yeah there we go okay so what's this
talk all about it's a history of
application security there's a couple
sub topics i want to show you that being
a jerk on twitter
can help make the world a more secure
place if you do it right
the third thing is that it's important
when you're giving a keynote if you have
friends in the office if you have
friends in the audience to invite them
on stage to get selfies so this is the
whole point history of application
security cool
how to be a jerk on twitter and save the
world and bringing your friends on stage
takes keynote selfies seem like a good
set of topics for today is this good
okay let's let's get to work my name is
jim manico
please say hello to me on twitter i'm a
former board member of owasp i'm an
author and i work on a lot of owass
projects in a leadership position let's
go back to ancient history of
application security the dark ages the
first major document in the west on
application security we see the 1960 the
task force
doing some of the first information
secure reports and this this is all
classified in the in the us
and by the defense advanced research
project agency darpa so they're doing
some classified
classified reports on information
security this is really the first time
we see professional publications it was
actually declassified a few years later
and we see in 1970 and
1975 the whole world gets to take a look
at this so this art and science of
information security is only about 50
years old at best so here and these
reports if we look at them
what do you think the summary of these
reports are this is the first time we
have real major i.t running government
military we have
some experts in information security
analyzing government systems
guess what the summary of their report
is about the status of information
security in the u.s government
yeah yeah is messed up
that that's a nice summary of the whole
report right there so let's take a look
at the history of security testing then
the first security testing device in
modern history is the bomb this is
written by this is actually built
not by the brits the brits did not crack
enigma it was actually done by a polish
researcher
he really didn't get a lot of credit in
history for the work he did but a team
of polish researchers are the ones who
actually built the research to crack um
to crack enigma and then and then the
british team took over that research
1972 we see the anderson report coming
out first collect first report first
testing report i know of in information
security we see the air force beginning
aggressive testing in the 70s we see in
1979 the first static analysis tool
right lint this is the first tool in
history to look at code to look for
security problems and now and there's a
dark age for about for about 20 years
but around 95 a tool called satan comes
out security administrator tool for
analyzing networks and this is the first
security scanning tool that almost every
security professional gets their hands
on this is the real beginning of the
automated security testing age around
you know not 1996.
that is not that long ago this i was a
professional writing code at the
beginning of my career
and that's when scanning tools first
came out
so let's zoom back
this is a brand new industry we are
still learning and maturing our
capabilities so 1998 we see jeff
forestall
at a usenix meeting a used next
publication on christmas day for the
first time we see the term sql injection
sql injection used as a term it's like
not that long ago and then 99 we see
cross-site scripting declared at
microsoft for the first time defined at
microsoft for the first time 2001 o wasp
is now active
web goat is released and i remember when
web go came out that changed everything
in application security because now all
of us doing application security like
all 50 of us or all like 20 of us we
were all looking at web goat attacking
it web goat is an education platform
it's a purposely insecure application
that with challenges to hack and now
everyone's downloading web goat and we
have a common a
common environment to discuss security
vulnerabilities for the first time it
accelerated the discussion of of
application security 2003 we get
metasploit 2006 the oauth testing guide
is first published by own kerry and
others 2010
owasp zap is released with an active
attack scanner i remember one of my
students downloading it using it
scanning a site and going to jail
because they were attacking sites with
this combat scanner this is meant for
assessment not to attack but anyways
let's move on 2013 is the beginning of
the devops era
this is where we see gene kim and some
of the early etsy employees automating
the security testing of software as part
of a block to checking in code and in
we see defect dojo come out from owasp
now this is hardcore
defect dojo is an open source
orchestration and testing and devops
framework i can go download oazap oas
dependency check semgrep and in like 20
minutes i have a full open source
scanning orchestration framework it is
amazing and this is the kind of stuff
that we would spend hundreds of hours
working on
it's now a download so we're making
radical progress 2020 we see a free
piece of software called semgrep
released this is the first enterprise
class code scanning tool that you can
download and use for free it's a devops
tool it runs in like 30 seconds there's
there's semgrep there's shift left
there's sneak who has these capabilities
now we're seeing modern static analysis
tools being built that run fast for a
devops life cycle in 2022 today
dev sec ops the idea of automating
security testing as part of the
developer life cycle is now
the norm
it's now the main way i see most
companies doing code so where do we
start we started with a group of polish
researchers with hammer and nail and
wire
physically building a testing tool to
crack enigma
to save to save us from the horrors of
world war ii and flash forward to today
the norm is when i check code in
hundreds of security tests are run that
that enable me to run fast but also
checks my work to make sure i'm doing
security as i go as a developer how far
have we come in less than 50 years we've
come a long way
so that's the point i want you to zoom
out and look at the history of what our
industry is doing and you'll see today
we have security integrated into github
in mature ways we have a whole industry
like a 10 billion dollar industry of
application security scanning tools we
have pen testing is still expensive but
there's not enough people out there the
need for testing is there compliance is
growing open source tools are maturing
we have a lot of powerful tools at our
disposal today that were not even there
just a few years ago we're making
progress let's take a look at https next
we have an engineer at netscape
building https ssl 1.0 for the first
time by the way scott do you know the
certificate authority system that was
built back in 94 was that a mature piece
of engineering well thought out how is
the certificate authority system made in
94.
the engineer who built tls our https was
interviewed by moxie marlin spike at
black hat a couple years ago and and the
engineer was like oh yeah certificate
authority system i forgot about that
yeah we kind of slapped it in at the end
i mean the public key needs to be needs
to be have integrity we just kind of did
a little hand wave and slapping at the
end and that's and now like that's how
we do tls many years later so this is a
real crappy protocol like almost every
mistake that could have been made was
made and it was kind of like put
together in a half-assed way 1999
we see the first real mature version of
https released that's tls 1.0 this was
amazing when it came out back in 99 and
today it's a weakness it's a broken
protocol let's keep going 2006 and 2008
we see tls-11 also broken and in 2008
tls12 shows up this is robust
what's the problem with tls one two in
this era though the problem is
it's too complicated there's too many
ways to configure it and it's very easy
to misconfigure tls one two even though
it's decent right it's still a little
problematic
2009 a famous security researcher ivan
ristic releases ssl labs and to this day
ssl labs is the de facto standard
around how to analyze a website for tls
amazing researcher
why this was important is all of a
sudden we all have visibility into any
website instantly to see how well their
tls quests configured i am an internet
troll i worked hard to be the troll that
i am today so i grabbed the ssl url for
every single security company in our
industry and put the grade and began
tweeting this out and i remember sigil
at the time the biggest security
companies in our industry they had an f
and the executives of cigital start
tweeting at me oh man it goes wrong he
doesn't understand this and they went
after me hardcore and i'm like oh this
is drama i love it
ivan jumps in after this huge thread
ivan jumps in and says hey sigil i have
a suggestion
instead of hammering on mr manaco how
about you go fix your server and they
shut up real quick
so this is this now we get visibility
into the whole world of tls 2010 chrome
begins to pre-load strict transport
security in their browser for chrome
properties it's impossible to visit
google properties over http in their
browser because of this enforcement and
then we get fire sheep in 2011.
so so
hello fire sheep what are you doing the
sheep wants to stay that's okay around
this era we get fire sheep
fire sheep is important because it's an
easy plug-in on a mac and i can
immediately hijack http sessions on a
public network this was amazing i just
go to the coffee shop run fire sheep my
friends would log into facebook and i go
hijack with their permission ethically
of course scott
you know ethically of course so so 2013
this is when tls is live in all major
browsers 2015 we get let's encrypt a
free certificate authority i hate the
stupid authority industry so much
it's horrible so let's encrypt
is this open like is this non-profit um
group that really changed the game and
helped accelerate the use of https
around the world
to that by 2016 half of the web is https
by 2017 we see her certificate
uh a caa and 2018
we see the publication of tls 1.3 why is
tls 1.3 so important in history here
because for the first time we see a
protocol that has very little
configuration
there's not a lot of ways to roll out
tls one three they actually removed a
lot of the protocol to make it simple
and strong by default and now today in
2022 95 of pages loaded by chrome is tls
that is amazing change in a very short
amount of time and now we have tls13
everywhere
scott helm is in the audience here he's
one of the world's most renowned experts
and educators on on https i mean that
sincerely they've been watching your
career for a decade scott you're
fantastic i'm a big fan come on come up
here for a sec
come on
up here quick i got i got to talk to
dude let's i got to talk to you i got to
talk to you right there yeah tls one
three thank you this guy won't be
audience wait wait wait wait audio get
down get down get down come on come on
yeah
hey
scott i've been watching your career for
a decade the work you do in tls is
outstanding keep up the good work sir
i'm impressed so again the web is tls in
a matter of years
http will no longer be part of the web
with within a matter of like five years
is my guess we have come so far
we started with the netscape engineer in
94 going
yeah i got to do the authority system in
a hand way they made it with this broken
protocol and today we have an ultra
robust tls13
that's everywhere this is ssl labs you
can evaluate your site
okay
next topic let's talk about password
history and password security the first
place in history how you doing how's
everyone doing so far doing so far so
good you're doing all right
let's keep going
so in
we see mit's first
multi-user computer
this is a just a server like an old
mainframe that can handle multiple users
at once
now this service had something called a
message of the day
so when you log in they rotate through
like 10 different message of the days
welcome to the university thank you for
using our computer there was a bug in
this operating system though there's
like a buffer overload type of problem
where the the last message of the day
would be random passwords from other
users so literally you would just log in
and log out log in and log out and you'd
event and every couple messages would be
another user's password
this is
this is where fair
pair towards dean he's a member i get
your name right
how do you pronounce your last name
so pair so pam
pair the crazy password guy this is
where we pairs is part of the password
hashing competition he's one of the
world's experts in passwords
cryptography that helps par a group of
other cryptographers to decide on which
algorithm will be standard for password
storage this is a
crucial standard around building a login
system so a lot of famous people he's
famous to me good to see you there and
so 1970 crypt crypt 3 comes out this is
real this is a like old school unix and
they ripped this from an old m209
decryption device from world war ii
it doesn't get much worse than this this
is a really bad algorithm that was
already broken by the time they ported
it but it was all we had so these are
really easily crackable weak ways to
store a password now 78 uh we see that
three is released it's now d a des
based and at this era it's a lot better
now so it's it's still like by today's
standard it's bad but this is the first
time we see the crucial cryptographic
pieces of crypt of password storage
stretching salting and a real password
policy so we're getting started here we
got something it's horrible but for that
era it was it was the best we had best
in the world actually by the by the 80s
we have a password database limited to
only the root user that early mit system
i could literally like read the password
file for the entire system
so for the first time now in the 80s we
see that password file
protected by root user only so it took
took a while so there's a decade of no
real advances and in 91 we see md5
message based password storage let me
jump ahead a little bit in 99 bcrip
shows up this is the first robust
password storage algorithm that some
people think that we should still use
today i am not one of them we'll talk
about that in just a second and then
let's jump ahead a bit we see pbk df2
a nist stand our u.s standard we see
what else let's just jump ahead here by
by 2016
a very famous uh professional
uh dr akaway from dropbox he releases an
article on how to use bcrypt with a
certain work factor pre-hashing to do
password storage for the first time in
history i'm given clear guidance in how
to do password storage cryptography in a
way that is still robust even today
so
real good password storage cryptography
is less than 10 years old
this is we've we've come a long way in a
short amount of time and now in 2022
around this just a few years ago argon
2id was chosen by pair and the rest of
the password hashing competition and in
2022 i defeated one of the other members
of that group jeremy ghazny in a rap
battle about password storage on twitter
let me show so this is the this is the
article from dr um dev data aquaway it
is it is a seminal article about how to
do passwords towards crypto better than
any article i've ever seen in that era
so argon 2id is now everywhere this is
the current most modern password storage
algorithm multi-factor is on the rise
making password storage a little bit
less important and let's talk about
jeremy so here we go i don't like bcrypt
and that's a fact argon 2id it's where
it's at 72 byte limit can kiss my ass
and low ram usage no thanks i'll pass
i'm just playing around on twitter i
swear a little bit too much i'm sicilian
i apologize
so all of a sudden jeremy gosney shows
up from the past he's a famous
cryptographer and he's like argon's a
kdf and that's no cap if you're doing
real time off you need beat crypt in
your app
memory hardness has no meat it's all fat
for resistance to acceleration cash
hardness is where it's at i'm like yeah
it's on jeremy so i'm like well jeremy
argon 2id won the passer competition for
passer storage you need a little
revision b crypt truncates and that's a
fact it's a blank limit it's easier to
attack argon 2id has better password
cracking resistance and i'm here to help
jeremy here's a reference the password
oh he did not like he he texted me and
like oh jim it is so on dude i'm like
all right
so which now jeremy is a world famous
password cracker which one of us is the
cracker
it seems you forgot and a hatch cat
developer i think you're not in the
password competition i was a judge for
that too with all these credentials
whose owes to argue
whoa
that's a pretty good hit in my response
the other judge has outvoted you and one
plus one still equals two oh
victory
sorry sorry jeremy
but it's
there you go all right pear get up here
come on get up here
sorry remember
history
selfies
and and tweet let's get down here you
ready yep
with the audience come on come out with
your audience
okay we got come on yeah
[Laughter]
pair has been passionate about password
security
every day i've ever talked to him he's
someone who's he's doving into that
topic deeper than anyone i know
thanks for all the great work you do for
our industry and i got to say jeremy
ghazni he's my he's a good friend he's
one of the world's best uh
cryptographers i've ever met he's
brilliant and we're just playing around
having fun
all right let's keep going so
in 2001 the open web application
security project is formed this is a
non-profit international foundation
dedicated to helping all of us learn
about application security
our mission is to make application
security visible so that people and
organizations can make informed
decisions about application security
risk all of our materials are free etc i
believe in no wasp it is a really like
there's a lot of mixed nuts in owasp i'm
one of them don't get me wrong it's not
perfect but owasp has helped me learn
about application security more than
anything else that i've ever interfaced
with by 2002 the developer's guide came
out
by 2008 we have the beginning of the
application security verification
standard the asvs standard 2008. 2009 we
see the first oas top 10 release
candidate one the xss prevention cheat
sheet is published by jeff williams most
popular resource on owasp to ever be
visited and we see the work of open sam
the software assurance maturity model
all open and free guides and tools
what else can we see at owasp 2015
we see the owasp dependency check a
third-party library security scanner are
you taking a picture of me sir wait one
more one more
go quick quick picture picture quick
all right all right
he's not he's not playing my game so
it's all right sorry sorry
so 2015 we have these we have security
shepard coming out a great capture the
flag system uh the work of juice shop
shows up from
from our german friends so we now have a
huge number of tools 2018 we see the
internet of things top 10
2020 there's 50 cheat sheets this is the
living encyclopedia of owasp promoted to
flagship hundreds of volunteers helping
us write guides in application security
and in 2022
we see the owasp top 10
2021 22 released and the application
security verification standard
4.03 released these are i believe these
are great documents the oaus top 10 is
where you start to learn a little
awareness about application security and
then the asvs standard is something more
comprehensive to base a whole program
off of these are guides that people
would usually pay consultants a great
deal of money to build for them and now
they're free they've gotten quite mature
in terms of their in terms of how
they're written
so we have a whole collection of
flagship projects at the uos foundation
to help you learn and actually do
application security
let's look at cross-site scripting next
i love this vulnerability category
because it is very complicated it's one
of the more difficult areas of
application security for a web developer
to get right we have all these promises
to fix this http only output and coding
automatic output encoding templates html
sanitization content security policy um
trusted types there's been so
many attempts to fix cross-site
scripting is it fixed yet
not at all it's it shows up everywhere
so cross-site scripting was first coined
as the term
sir you're late you're late for my talk
sorry sorry sorry
1999 we see microsoft engineers coin the
term cross-site scripting right and 2002
we see microsoft releasing the http only
flag in internet explorer six service
pack one
internet explorer six just saying that
word makes me feel physical pain just
for the record
wow let's let's move moving on and so
2005 sami kumkar from los angeles
decides to submit this little payload
against myspace
executing the first global cross-site
scripting worm in history this caused
the entire myspace global cluster to
blue screen and shut down and sammy
spent a couple years
sweeping like streets in l.a in a
jumpsuit to avoid going to jail but he
demonstrated to us that cross-site
scripting is real and the damage that
could be done with it is real and this
really accelerated the whole security
industry i remember people looking at
this in our industry going i can't
believe sammy did that against myspace
that is a terrible criminal act
yes we're so cause
even though it was a criminal act that
harmed my space it bred awareness about
application security like nothing else
in that era of time all of a sudden i
got calls and budget and people want to
do security so sammy
doing evil helped the world be a more
secure place my kind of guy let's keep
going dude so 2005 amit klein first
publishes an article about dom-based xss
this article is completely incorrect
when we look at it today but at the time
it was it was good analysis let me jump
ahead a bit what else
so two
2012 is a big important part of history
this is where content security policy
1.0 is published
this is an
even more important standard as time
goes on because we're realizing even
with our frameworks and and philip no
one likes angular i'm sorry
with the other non-angular frameworks we
don't get free security so to so and
developers who really understand using
these frameworks securely is
unfortunately rare so content security
policy is this extra layer i can add on
top of a web app to really lock down the
browser in a variety of different ways
and here we have csp2 published in 2014
csp3 published in 2015
and trusted type shows up in 2020. now
what's the problem in 2020 every single
browser is supporting content security
policy 3 except for one browser safari
it is really frustrating they did roll
it out recently
but as you may guess there's a story
behind that
so here we go august of 2021
i'm tweeting i believe that safari's
lack of cs3c support and similar w3
standards is a reason to boycat and stop
using it out to 20 000 followers i now
see safari as a browser that impedes the
secure web edge chrome firefox all
support csp3 but why not safari so i'm
being a jerk and i'm well i'm open to
counter opinions that's saying i know
i'm being a jerk and i'm trying to like
excuse myself so anyways all of a sudden
dr philippe shows up because people are
saying safari is not important and
felipe jumps in and says well that holds
for a lot of people but the market share
is not insignificant folks i use brave
but safari is eight percent and this is
important
come on phillip
selfies with friends
let's do this right on philip well with
the audience with the audience come on
get down come on
thank you man phillip is one of my
favorite instructors in the world of
oauth 2 and open id connect
who was at breakfast with us
uh well ander anders
he said he wouldn't go to my talk so
he's not here ander
so phil philip is an instructor in the
world of oauth 2 and oidc
i'm a big fan philip so here we go
um
august of 2021 i'm not trying to harass
john by the way the head of of safari
security is john wylander and he's uh
he's a swedish man
you know what they say about the swedes
they're great people right so let's
let's move on so john john john is
swedish and he runs the whole security
team for safari and i'm like really
attacking john but trying not to and
john's like he's a man of respect he
really is he's like jim don't worry i
want to see csp3 in webkit as well and
always forward good faith feedback to
the team
if you want to talk to the person in
charge he's blah now guess what the next
tweet
is lucas weisselbaum
do you know who lucas is by the way
here's lucas lucas is a senior staff
information security engineer at google
out of zurich let's be clear he's one of
the most senior content security policy
engineers at google so
apple is like yeah we haven't built it
yet we're thinking about it i'm going to
forward this to our lead and google says
hey we'll do it for you apple
and i'm like oh my god drama i'm so
excited this is all under the thread
where i'm bitching at safari right go
lucas john's like absolutely webkit's
open source it's not just apple building
web platform yeah it's pretty much only
for apple sorry john so
we haven't expressed opposition to csp
one it isn't backwards compatible it's
too complex so john's like he's not
drank in the kool-aid of content
security policy who believes in content
security policy all right there's enough
so it's okay john john hasn't quite
drank the kool-aid so lucas is like he's
being really respectful thank you was
opposition about strict dynamic one of
the most important flags in content
security policy we think it makes
deployment easier so he knows just what
to say to john and john's like well we
want to split up csp we want to fork it
off we don't want we don't want to do it
that's okay john i and lucas i get it
i also agree it would make sense to fork
off scripting let me go talk to some
folks and i'll come i'll get back to you
and all of a sudden and this all goes
away behind the scenes i'm getting texts
from john getting texts from lucas
getting texts from michelle spagniolo
and everyone's talking behind the scenes
and i want to respect their privacy and
not get into it but let's jump ahead
like five minutes later or five months
later
all of a sudden
i i i get note from john that kate
cheney from apple is implementing
content security policy three not
because google hired a bunch of
engineers to start working on it and
they did
and for some reason apple
was not happy that google engineers were
donating their time and money to help
webkit
implement content security policy 3 so
safari could get better better security
and whatever for whatever reason apple
executives were like no this is not
going to happen so they assigned kate
cheney who's awesome to do csp3 and she
begins working on it and suddenly i get
this from john just a couple weeks ago
hey jim webkit and safari 15.4 approved
support for content security policy
level 3 new support for strict dynamic
unsafe hashes report sample
happy to deliver this message my friend
john is one of the best people in our
industry i've ever met he is just a
hundred percent good people i am this
and this made me
i couldn't believe this happened it's
john this makes me beam with joy thank
you and your team for their hard work in
delivering this critical security canada
security standard to safari
what's the moral of the story here
be a jerk on twitter but do it for the
right reason right and don't be too much
of a jerk on twitter
just a little bit just a little bit so
you can be a jerk on twitter and make
the world a more secure place this is
not about me though this is about this
team here this is john wylander the head
of safari security this is kat i'm
respecting her privacy catherine chaney
who's the engineer who built csp into
safari and my personal heroes from
google yes thank you boys lucas
weishelbaum and michelle spagnolo the
two gentlemen who rolled out content
security policy in the real world more
than any two people in the
any two people in the world so let's
recap all of this let's go back let's go
back a step let's look at the history of
content security policy in 99 microsoft
defines the term
it is everywhere in every app and the
web is a very fragile place in this era
blink ahead to today just a couple weeks
ago we have one of the most modern
progressive easy to deploy standards in
the world available in every major
browser with with the most advanced
standard so it's easy to roll out so
what's the point you look at the problem
of fixing xss
as a developer as security person it's
brutally difficult to handle
but if you zoom out and look at where
how far we've come the advancements in
only 20 years
is amazingly dramatic and we have the
tools and ability to solve this problem
today more than ever before we still
have a lot of work to do we're still
rolling out trusted types and even newer
standard that that we see being woven
into frameworks today
so what do we got auto escaping to stop
cross-site scripting is the norm in all
major frameworks vue
react angular svelt they all do it csp3
was trick dynamic just from a few weeks
ago is live in every major browser
trusted types is available in many
frameworks
and being a little bit of a jerk on
twitter can help make the world a more
secure place all right
i'm winding down here let me jump ahead
a bit pardon me
let's come to a conclusion here i'm not
going to spend the whole hour i'm going
to wind it down
we look at today and application
security chapters for the owasp
foundation is 260 locations around the
world from hawaii to uh the
to nepal and kathmandu has a chapter
so the the people i know in owasp around
the world that i collaborate with and
communicate with and give talks to
because of owasp i have friends in the
security industry in almost every corner
of the planet and that is a gift to my
life so when i when i think about olaf i
give this talk to you i tell you these
jokes and stories what really goes
through my mind is o wasp has been the
greatest gift to my life in terms of
teaching me about application security
giving me chances to travel the world
and speak and most importantly
to collaborate with brilliant people
like scott and pair and felipe and the
rest of you here
so here's one last moment in application
security history that i want to bring up
and that's today
ndc security here in norway a giant
security conference dedicated to
application security this is important
that we're here that you care about
security enough to show up here
let's talk about the future of apsec for
a second as we finish this talk up
so cons
i don't know what the future has to
bring
it's not about me
it's not about an idea it's not even
about a technology or a concept or or
some brilliant thing i can think about
you know what the future of appsec
really is
the future of appsec is you it's
everyone in this room who shows up to
this conference who cares about security
who fights the fight and tries to make
the world a more secure place in some
way
the future of application security is
you
thank you very much
[Applause]
you